- Bienvenue dans « Comprendre l'information
et le calcul quantiques ». Je m'appelle John Watrous, et je suis le Directeur Technique
de l'éducation quantique chez IBM.
C'est la cinquième leçon de la série, et c'est la première leçon de
la deuxième unité de la série, qui porte sur les algorithmes quantiques.
Dans cette unité, nous allons explorer
les avantages computationnels de l'information quantique, c'est-à-dire que nous allons
voir ce qu'on peut faire
avec des ordinateurs quantiques et les avantages que les ordinateurs quantiques pourraient potentiellement avoir
sur les ordinateurs classiques.
On va se concentrer sur ce qu'on peut faire avec un seul ordinateur quantique plutôt que dans un contexte distribué,
par exemple,
où plusieurs ordinateurs quantiques interagissent via un réseau quelconque.
Il existe en fait des avantages quantiques dans les contextes distribués, où la communication et
la cryptographie entrent en jeu,
mais on ne va pas
en parler dans cette unité.
Cette unité porte sur les algorithmes quantiques s'exécutant sur des ordinateurs quantiques uniques.
Commençons par une question naturelle. Quels avantages un ordinateur
quantique pourrait-il potentiellement offrir ?
Le principal est que les ordinateurs quantiques pourraient fournir des solutions plus rapides à certains problèmes computationnels.
Le temps est précieux, et bien que les ordinateurs qu'on
utilise au quotidien soient assez rapides, ils sont encore bien trop lents
pour résoudre certains problèmes computationnels simplement en raison de la difficulté
computationnelle inhérente à ces problèmes.
Ce potentiel que les ordinateurs quantiques nous permettent de résoudre des problèmes que les ordinateurs classiques
sont trop lents pour résoudre
est vraiment ce qui a motivé
la recherche sur les algorithmes quantiques au cours des dernières décennies.
Il existe d'autres ressources computationnelles
outre le temps qui peuvent être considérées, comme la quantité de mémoire informatique nécessaire aux calculs,
mais les ordinateurs quantiques ne peuvent pas
offrir beaucoup d'économies en termes de mémoire, en fin de compte, et la mémoire des ordinateurs classiques est assez bon marché
particulièrement comparée à la mémoire quantique. Donc il n'y a pas vraiment
beaucoup d'espoir ici.
On pourrait aussi penser à d'autres ressources comme la quantité d'énergie
nécessaire pour le calcul, mais tu n'as en fait pas
besoin de beaucoup d'énergie du tout
pour calculer classiquement, surtout si tu es
prêt à ralentir les choses.
Donc c'est vraiment le temps
nécessaire aux calculs qui est notre principal objectif.
Voici un aperçu de la leçon, qui porte sur un modèle spécifique
de calcul connu sous le nom de modèle à requêtes.
Tu peux considérer ce modèle comme une sorte de boîte de Petri pour développer des idées algorithmiques, aussi bien quantiques que classiques.
Il n'est pas censé être un modèle pratique qui décrit les types
de problèmes computationnels que l'on rencontre dans la vie réelle.
Nous allons nous éloigner du modèle à requêtes dans les leçons suivantes de cette unité et nous concentrer plutôt sur des modèles motivés par des notions
de calcul plus pratiques,
mais le modèle à requêtes est un
très bon point de départ.
C'est un modèle simple qui nous permet d'explorer le
potentiel des ordinateurs quantiques sans être encombrés par de nombreux détails techniques,
et il nous permet aussi d'isoler certaines des
idées vraiment importantes derrière le calcul quantique et son fonctionnement.
Le calcul quantique s'est en fait d'abord développé dans ce modèle, et les idées qui ont été
développées en son sein ont directement inspiré
d'importants algorithmes quantiques
comme l'algorithme de Shor pour la factorisation.
Dans la première section de la leçon, nous allons voir précisément ce qu'est le modèle à requêtes de calcul,
et dans les deuxième, troisième
et quatrième sections, nous allons discuter de trois
algorithmes quantiques à requêtes, à savoir l'algorithme de Deutsch,
l'algorithme de Deutsch-Jozsa
et l'algorithme de Simon, qui révèlent des avantages de plus en plus
impressionnants
des ordinateurs quantiques
sur les ordinateurs classiques dans le cadre du modèle à requêtes.
Pour expliquer le modèle à requêtes, commençons d'abord par une abstraction plus standard
du calcul.
Voici une figure qui
représente un calcul en termes très simples et fondamentaux.
On a une entrée, qui prend généralement la
forme d'une chaîne binaire, bien qu'on puisse utiliser d'autres
symboles si on le souhaitait.
L'entrée est fournie au calcul, qui est représenté par un
rectangle bleu dans cette figure,
et le résultat du calcul est qu'une sortie est produite, et là encore, c'est le plus souvent
une chaîne binaire.
Bien sûr, cette figure
n'est pas du tout précise sur la façon dont le calcul lui-même fonctionne.
On peut formuler différents
modèles computationnels spécifiques pour cela, tels que les machines de Turing
et les circuit booléens,
ou les circuit quantiques si on réfléchit au
calcul quantique.
Il est vrai que cette figure
ne représente pas le fait que beaucoup d'ordinateurs qu'on utilise au quotidien reçoivent continuellement
des entrées et produisent des sorties,
interagissant essentiellement avec nous et avec d'autres ordinateurs via
internet, par exemple.
Mais on n'essaie pas de représenter
ces interactions ici.
Il s'agit de modéliser
des tâches computationnelles isolées.
Par exemple, l'entrée pourrait être le
codage binaire d'un nombre ou une représentation d'une matrice
WEBVTT
ou la description d'une molécule ou vraiment n'importe quoi d'autre qu'on a en tête, et il y a une tâche computationnelle
effectuée sur cette entrée seule.
Le point clé ici est
que l'entrée entière est fournie au calcul, et rien à propos de l'entrée ne lui est caché.
Le modèle à requêtes
fonctionne différemment.
Dans le modèle à requêtes, l'entrée est rendue disponible
sous la forme d'une fonction à laquelle le calcul peut
accéder en effectuant des requêtes,
ou en d'autres termes, en évaluant la fonction
sur différentes entrées.
Tu peux voir cela représenté
sous la forme d'une figure ici.
Similaire à ce qu'on avait avant, le calcul est représenté
par un rectangle bleu, mais au lieu de recevoir une entrée directement
sous la forme d'une chaîne
de bits, par exemple, il accède à l'entrée en posant effectivement des questions
et en recevant des réponses.
On utilise parfois les termes
oracle et boîte noire pour désigner le mécanisme
qui fournit l'entrée.
Il existe une distinction entre
un oracle et une boîte noire en théorie de la complexité, mais cela ne sera pas du tout pertinent pour les besoins de cette discussion.
Quoi qu'il en soit, ces termes sont censés
transmettre l'idée de base.
Dans la Grèce antique, tu
pouvais aller voir un oracle, comme l'Oracle de Delphes,
et poser une question importante,
et l'oracle répondrait
à cette question spécifique, mais elle ne te dirait certainement pas tout ce qu'elle savait.
Dans le même ordre d'idées, quand
on pense à une boîte noire, on a en tête un certain
type de processus ou de système
où on peut choisir ce qui entre et on peut voir ce qui sort, mais on n'a aucune compréhension
de son fonctionnement interne.
Et c'est le cas ici. L'entrée du problème
prend la forme d'une fonction, et tout ce qu'on peut faire c'est
d'évaluer cette fonction,
mais autrement, on n'a
aucune connaissance ni compréhension de la façon dont elle fonctionne.
Tout au long de la leçon,
on réservera la lettre f pour la fonction qui
représente l'entrée, et on va supposer
qu'elle prend toujours la
forme que tu vois ici.
Sigma désigne l'alphabet binaire, donc f est une fonction des chaînes
de bits vers des chaînes de bits,
et plus précisément, on va
supposer que l'entrée de f est une chaîne de bits de longueur n, et la sortie est une chaîne
de bits de longueur m,
où n et m sont des entiers positifs.
Pour différents problèmes, on aura
des restrictions sur n et m, mais dans tous les cas, la fonction d'entrée
prendra une forme comme celle-ci.
Quand on dit qu'un
calcul effectue une requête, ce qu'on veut dire c'est que la
fonction f est évaluée une fois,
c'est-à-dire qu'une certaine chaîne x de longueur N est sélectionnée par le calcul, et la chaîne f de x est
ensuite rendue disponible
par l'oracle ou la boîte noire. Et enfin, la façon très simple dont on va mesurer le coût computationnel
d'un algorithme à requêtes est de compter combien de requêtes il nécessite.
Ainsi, bien qu'il soit vrai que
nous nous intéressons principalement à la durée des calculs, quand on étudie le modèle à requêtes,
on garde généralement les choses
simples et on compte simplement les requêtes, et c'est ce qu'on va faire dans cette leçon.
Maintenant, regardons quelques
exemples de problèmes à requêtes, c'est-à-dire des problèmes computationnels dans le modèle à requêtes,
et ici, au passage, je vais juste décrire
les problèmes eux-mêmes, et à ce stade, je ne dirai rien
sur la façon de les résoudre.
Le premier problème est le problème OU.
Dans ce cas, l'entrée est une fonction
de n bits vers juste 1 bit, donc m est égal à 1 pour ce problème,
et la sortie requise pour
le problème est soit 1 soit 0.
S'il existe une chaîne de n bits x pour laquelle f de x est égal à 1, alors la bonne réponse est 1,
et sinon, si f de x est
toujours 0 pour toute chaîne x, alors la bonne réponse est 0.
Donc si on pense à la fonction f comme nous donnant un accès aléatoire à deux puissance n bits, un pour chaque chaîne de n bits x,
alors ce qu'on demande
c'est le OU de ces bits, et c'est pourquoi ça s'appelle le problème OU.
Un autre exemple est le problème de parité, qui est similaire au problème OU sauf qu'il demande la parité,
ou en d'autres termes, le OU exclusif de toutes les valeurs de sortie à
un seul bit de la fonction.
Une autre façon de le dire c'est
que la bonne réponse est 0 si le nombre de chaînes de n bits x pour lesquelles f de x est égal à 1 est pair,
et la bonne réponse est
1 si ce nombre est impair.
Un exemple de problème où m n'est pas nécessairement égal à 1 est le problème du minimum.
Ici, la fonction f prend la forme habituelle, et il n'y a pas de restrictions sur n et m,
et la bonne réponse est quelle que soit la valeur de sortie
de la fonction qui vient en premier dans l'ordre lexicographique
ou alphabétique
des chaînes binaires. Autrement, si tu veux
penser aux chaînes de longueur m comme représentant des entiers non négatifs
en notation binaire,
alors la bonne réponse
est la valeur la plus petite possible ou minimale qui
sort de cette fonction.
WEBVTT
Parfois, on considère aussi des problèmes à requêtes où on a une promesse
sur la fonction d'entrée, ou en d'autres termes, une certaine
garantie sur elle,
et on ne se préoccupe pas des fonctions qui ne remplissent pas cette promesse.
Les fonctions qui ne satisfont pas la promesse sont considérées comme des entrées « don't care ».
Et on n'est tout simplement pas responsable de ce qui se passe sur ces entrées.
Voici un exemple de problème à requêtes avec une promesse appelé recherche unique.
C'est lié au problème OU,
mais c'est différent.
La fonction d'entrée a la même
forme que pour le problème OU, c'est-à-dire qu'elle prend
des chaînes de n bits vers des bits.
Cette fois, on nous promet qu'il
existe exactement une chaîne Z qui fait évaluer f à 1,
avec f de x étant égal à 0
pour toute chaîne x différente de z, et la sortie correcte
est cette unique chaîne z.
Bien sûr, il y a des
choix pour la fonction f qui ne satisfont pas cette condition, mais on ne place aucune exigence du tout
sur les algorithmes pour ce problème quand on leur donne de telles
fonctions en entrée.
On ne se préoccupe que des fonctions qui satisfont la promesse.
Maintenant, tous les quatre
problèmes que je viens de mentionner sont des problèmes assez naturels, ce qui signifie qu'il est facile de les expliquer,
et il est facile d'imaginer des situations dans lesquelles le besoin de les résoudre pourrait se présenter, mais certains problèmes à requêtes
ne sont pas du tout comme ça.
En fait, parfois, on considère des problèmes à requêtes très
artificiels, où il est difficile d'imaginer que quelqu'un veuille jamais
réellement les résoudre.
Le problème de Simon, qu'on verra
plus loin dans la leçon, appartient un peu à cette catégorie, mais il y en a d'autres
qui sont bien pires dans un certain sens, mais qui s'avèrent néanmoins assez importants pour l'étude du modèle à requêtes.
On n'étudie pas ces problèmes parce qu'on veut nécessairement
les résoudre en pratique.
La façon dont tu peux le voir, c'est qu'on cherche
des extrêmes de diverses sortes,
en particulier, quand on travaille dans
cette boîte de Petri qu'est le modèle, une façon naturelle d'explorer
des idées algorithmiques quantiques
est de formuler des problèmes très artificiels, où on peut mieux exploiter la
puissance des ordinateurs quantiques.
Et cela peut en fait
éclairer grandement la façon dont les ordinateurs quantiques
peuvent potentiellement être utiles dans des contextes plus pratiques.
On peut formaliser la notion
de requête de différentes façons selon le modèle computationnel
avec lequel on travaille.
Par exemple, dans le modèle de la machine de Turing
de calcul, dont on n'a pas parlé et qu'on n'abordera pas dans cette série,
il y a une certaine façon de
formaliser la notion de requête qui est logique pour ce modèle.
Pour les modèles à circuit, on définit des types spéciaux de
gate appelées gate de requête, et c'est ainsi que les requêtes
sont formellement représentées.
Pour les circuit booléens, il y a une façon très simple de faire cela, qui consiste simplement à imaginer
qu'on a des gate de requête
qui évaluent la fonction d'entrée directement, comme tu peux le voir ici à l'écran.
L'idée est qu'on peut
utiliser ces gate de requête pour construire des circuit qui résolvent n'importe quel
problème qu'on regarde,
et pour fonctionner correctement, les circuit doivent donner la bonne réponse pour quelle que soit la fonction d'entrée f donnée,
en supposant qu'elle satisfait la promesse dans le cas d'un problème avec promesse.
Voici un exemple simple
d'un circuit booléen qui résout le problème de parité quand n est égal à 1,
donc la fonction d'entrée f va
de 1 bit à 1 bit dans ce cas.
Ce que ce circuit fait c'est d'évaluer la fonction
f sur les entrées 0 et 1 en utilisant ces deux gate de requête.
Il insère ensuite les deux valeurs de sortie qu'il
obtient des gate de requête dans le circuit booléen de la leçon trois qui calcule le XOR,
ce qui est la même chose que la parité.
Pour être clair, ces deux
valeurs d'entrée ici ne sont pas des entrées du problème,
c'est-à-dire le problème de parité,
quand on travaille avec le modèle à requêtes, l'entrée du problème
est la fonction f, et tu dois penser à ces
deux entrées dans le circuit
comme des valeurs codées en dur
qui ne changent jamais, elles font essentiellement partie de l'algorithme.
On veut calculer le XOR de f 0 et f 1, donc on initialise ces
deux fils de cette façon
pour que ça fonctionne. On a utilisé deux gate de requête
ici, celle-ci et celle-là,
et donc l'algorithme représenté
par ce circuit booléen effectue deux requêtes, et si on réfléchit au problème de parité un moment
pour des fonctions de un bit à un bit, on voit qu'il est absolument nécessaire pour tout circuit booléen
qui résout ce problème
d'effectuer au moins deux requêtes.
Si tu n'effectues qu'une seule requête de sorte que tu ne connais qu'une seule
valeur de sortie de la fonction f et pas l'autre, tu n'as en fait
aucune information du tout
sur la parité, parce que l'autre valeur de sortie
pourrait tout aussi bien être 0 ou 1, menant à l'une ou l'autre des
deux solutions possibles
au problème. Donc en termes du nombre
de requêtes qu'il effectue, ce circuit booléen est aussi bon qu'on peut faire
pour le problème de parité
quand n est égal à 1.
WEBVTT
Il y a un autre point concernant les gate de requête qui mérite d'être mentionné avant qu'on passe à autre chose, à savoir que quand on conçoit et analyse des algorithmes à requêtes,
on ne se préoccupe pas du tout de la façon dont
les gate de requête sont implémentées.
On suppose que ces
gate de requête nous sont données, et la difficulté de les construire
ne nous concerne pas.
Tu peux penser aux
gate de requête elles-mêmes comme étant l'entrée si tu veux, et ce n'est pas notre travail de créer l'entrée, on essaie juste de
résoudre un problème particulier
à partir de l'entrée. Bien sûr, quand f est une fonction
de un bit à un bit, il n'y a que quatre choix possibles,
et il serait assez facile
d'en implémenter n'importe lequel, mais en général, pour des fonctions
avec beaucoup de bits d'entrée,
il pourrait être extrêmement difficile d'implémenter des gate de requête
pour ces fonctions.
Pour être clair, ce n'est pas
pour dire que la question de la façon dont les gate de requête sont
implémentées n'est pas importante, mais plutôt qu'elle n'est pas considérée
comme faisant partie du coût
d'un algorithme à requêtes.
C'est cohérent avec l'idée que ce n'est pas vraiment
du calcul pratique ou de la construction réelle de circuit en tant que tels,
il s'agit de travailler dans
un cadre théorique qui nous dit des choses intéressantes
sur le calcul.
On aura plus à dire là-dessus quand on fera le saut de ce modèle vers un modèle de calcul plus standard, et c'est principalement ce dont la prochaine leçon,
la Leçon 6, va traiter.
Maintenant passons à
notre attention sur les circuit quantiques.
Pour les circuit quantiques, on va changer la
définition des gate de requête pour les rendre unitaires.
On veut pouvoir effectuer des
requêtes dans les circuit quantiques et qu'elles opèrent
linéairement sur les états quantiques
pour qu'on puisse effectivement
effectuer des requêtes en superposition.
Il pourrait sembler qu'on déplace
les poteaux, pour ainsi dire, en changeant ce qu'on entend par requête par rapport à ce qu'on vient de
voir pour les circuit booléens,
mais il y a une justification pour cela qu'on discutera plus
en détail dans la prochaine leçon.
Pour l'instant, c'est juste une définition.
Plus précisément, la
définition est la suivante : étant donné une fonction f de
la même forme qu'avant,
c'est-à-dire qu'elle transforme des chaînes de n bits
en chaînes de m bits, la gate de requête Uf agit sur n + m qubit
et est définie par l'
action décrite ici sur les états de la base standard.
On va voir une figure
représentant cette définition dans un moment, mais d'abord, laisse-moi clarifier la notation
utilisée ici,
à savoir que chaque fois qu'on
utilise le symbole du XOR comme opération entre deux
chaînes de même longueur,
on fait référence au
OU exclusif bit à bit, et tu peux voir un exemple ici.
Dans la définition, on a que y et f de
x sont des chaînes de longueur m, donc cette chaîne ici
représente la chaîne qu'on obtient
en faisant un XOR de ces deux chaînes
ensemble, un bit à la fois, et voici le diagramme
expliquant comment ces gate fonctionnent.
Les n qubit du dessus correspondent à
l'argument de la fonction.
Et quand ils commencent dans
un état de base standard, ket x dans ce diagramme, cet état de base standard
traverse inchangé
et est répercuté comme partie de la sortie.
Les m qubit du dessous correspondent à la sortie
de la fonction f, et quand ils commencent dans
n'importe quel état de base standard,
ket y dans ce diagramme, ce qui se passe c'est que la
sortie de la fonction f de x est XORée sur la chaîne y.
C'est ce qui se passe pour
les états de base standard, et si on veut savoir
ce qui se passe en général pour d'autres états quantiques, on
utilise la linéarité, comme on le fait toujours.
Une raison de définir les gate de requête comme ça où on répercute l'entrée et on utilise le XOR bit à bit pour la sortie
est que ces gate sont toujours unitaires pour tout choix de la fonction f.
C'est en fait une
opération déterministe.
Et si on devait l'exprimer comme une matrice pour tout choix d'une fonction F, on obtiendrait une matrice de permutation,
c'est-à-dire une matrice avec un seul un dans chaque ligne et dans chaque colonne, et toutes les autres entrées égales à 0.
Et les matrices de permutation
sont toujours unitaires.
En fait, pour cette opération, on va avoir que l'opération
est sa propre inverse, donc Uf dagger est égal à Uf.
Si tout ce qu'on veut faire avec ces
gate c'est d'évaluer f de x pour une certaine chaîne x, c'est facile,
on peut simplement mettre y à
la chaîne tout-zéro. Donc quand on fait le XOR bit à bit y, on finit avec juste f de x.
Ici, au passage, tu peux voir la notation utilisée pour désigner la chaîne tout-zéro.
Ça ressemble à 0 à la puissance M, mais ce n'est pas ce que ça signifie.
Ça signifie la chaîne de zéros
de longueur égale à M.
Quand on parle de
chaînes par opposition aux nombres, les exposants signifient généralement qu'on répète cette chaîne
un certain nombre de fois,
donc c'est 0 répété m fois.
WEBVTT
C'est juste une façon commode et précise de décrire cette chaîne.
Encore une fois, quand on
travaille avec le modèle à requêtes, on ne se préoccupe pas de la façon d'implémenter ces gate de requête.
C'est le même problème
qu'on avait avec les gate de requête pour les circuit booléens.
Ce n'est pas notre travail de préparer l'entrée, on nous donne l'entrée sous
la forme de ces gate de requête.
Je vais cependant faire remarquer que si on sait comment
implémenter la fonction f à l'aide d'un circuit booléen, alors il est possible de
traduire cette implémentation
assez directement en une
implémentation en circuit quantique de Uf, et on verra exactement comment
ça fonctionne dans la prochaine leçon.
Soit dit en passant, il est assez simple de créer un circuit booléen
qui fonctionne comme ça, en utilisant une seule
gate de requête classique pour la fonction f,
mais c'est très différent d'avoir une
implémentation en circuit quantique de cette gate unitaire.
Le point, cependant, est que
pour les algorithmes à requêtes classiques, avoir une gate de requête qui fonctionne comme ça est en fait équivalent
à avoir une gate de
requête classique ordinaire pour f, dans le sens où l'une peut être implémentée à l'aide de l'autre.
Dans cette section de la leçon, on va discuter de l'algorithme de Deutsch, qui est un algorithme à requêtes quantique très simple, mais c'est vraiment un joyau.
Cet algorithme vient d'un article de 1985 écrit par David Deutsch, qui fut l'une des toutes premières personnes à travailler sur les fondements théoriques
de l'informatique quantique.
L'algorithme lui-même représente une très petite partie
de l'article de 1985 de Deutsch, et en fait,
l'algorithme qu'on appelle maintenant
l'algorithme de Deutsch est en fait une version améliorée de l'algorithme que Deutsch avait décrit.
Il fournit un exemple très modeste de la façon dont les ordinateurs quantiques peuvent
offrir des avantages computationnels, mais il faut bien commencer quelque part,
et c'était vraiment une étincelle importante qui a lancé les choses.
L'algorithme de Deutsch résout un problème à requêtes souvent appelé le problème de Deutsch dans le contexte du calcul quantique,
mais en fait, ce n'est rien d'autre
que le problème de parité pour les fonctions de un bit à un bit, dont on a déjà parlé.
Comme on l'a déjà vu, il y a quatre fonctions
de un bit à un bit, et elles sont décrites ici à l'écran par leurs tables de valeurs.
La première et la dernière de ces
fonctions sont constantes, tandis que les deux du milieu sont équilibrées dans le sens où les deux
valeurs de sortie possibles
apparaissent le même nombre de fois.
Pour les deux fonctions constantes,
on voit que la parité, ou en d'autres termes, le OU exclusif des deux sorties est 0,
et pour les deux fonctions équilibrées, la parité des sorties est 1.
Donc une façon équivalente de
décrire le problème de parité dans ce cas particulier, où la fonction f prend
un seul bit en entrée,
ou en d'autres termes, le problème de Deutsch, est comme tu le vois ici.
L'entrée est une fonction f
de un bit à un bit, et la sortie est 0 si f est constante
et 1 si f est équilibrée.
Comme je l'ai déjà suggéré, tout algorithme à requêtes classique
qui résout ce problème doit effectuer au moins deux requêtes à f.
Si tu ne connais qu'une seule des
deux valeurs de sortie de f, tu n'as toujours aucune information du tout sur la parité des deux sorties.
Et ceci, au passage, est vrai
même pour les algorithmes classiques qui utilisent de l'aléatoire.
L'aléatoire peut parfois être très utile pour résoudre des problèmes à requêtes, et on verra un exemple
un peu plus tard dans la leçon,
mais l'aléatoire n'aide pas ici.
Donc notre algorithme de tout à l'heure est optimal parmi les algorithmes à requêtes classiques
pour le problème de Deutsch.
Maintenant on va voir
l'algorithme de Deutsch, qui est un algorithme à requêtes quantique qui résout le problème de Deutsch
en utilisant une seule requête.
Et voici l'algorithme
décrit comme un circuit quantique.
On a deux qubit
initialisés comme tu le vois ici, le premier initialisé à ket 0 et le deuxième initialisé à ket 1,
et on verra pourquoi on initialise ces qubit comme ça dans un moment.
On effectue des gate Hadamard
sur les deux qubit, on les passe dans la gate de requête, on effectue une autre gate Hadamard
sur le qubit du dessus,
et puis on le mesure. Et la prétention est que
le résultat de la mesure nous donne, avec certitude, la
bonne réponse au problème.
Alors analysons le
circuit étape par étape pour voir exactement comment il fonctionne.
L'état des deux qubit après la première couche de gate Hadamard est le produit tensoriel
des états moins et plus.
La Hadamard du dessus transforme
l'état 0 en un état plus, et la Hadamard du dessous transforme l'état 1 en un état moins.
Le qubit du dessus est à droite, et le qubit du dessous est à gauche, donc c'est l'état qu'on obtient.
Il est très important que le qubit du dessous soit dans un état moins, au passage, cela ne fonctionnerait pas si on
initialise le qubit du dessous
à un état 0 au lieu d'un état 1.
On va développer cet état
à moitié, comme tu le vois ici.
La raison de faire ça
n'est pas claire à ce stade, mais ce sera pratique
dans un moment.
Ensuite, réfléchissons à
l'état des deux qubit après que la gate de requête est effectuée.
La façon dont la gate de requête
fonctionne c'est qu'elle calcule F sur l'état de base standard
du qubit du dessus et XOR la valeur
sur le qubit du dessous,
WEBVTT
et ici on peut voir le
résultat de cette opération.
Pour le premier terme, l'état de base standard
du qubit du dessus est 0, donc f de zéro est XORé
sur le qubit du dessous,
et ça fonctionne par linéarité. Et c'est similaire pour le deuxième terme, sauf que l'état de base standard
du qubit du dessus est 1, donc on XOR f de 1 sur le qubit du dessous.
Et à ce stade, on peut
simplifier cette expression en observant la formule
qu'on peut voir ici en bas, qui fonctionne quand a est soit 0 soit 1.
Et on peut simplement vérifier ça pour ces deux valeurs séparément.
Si a est égal à 0, alors
XORer avec a ne fait rien, et moins 1 à la puissance 0 est 1,
donc les deux côtés sont égaux. Et si a est égal à 1, on obtient ket 1 moins ket
0 quand on fait le XOR,
ce qui est moins 1
fois ket 0 moins ket 1.
Et si on utilise cette formule
pour simplifier notre état, où on prend a égal
à f de 0 à gauche et a égal à f de 1 à droite,
on obtient l'expression
que tu vois ici.
Donc quand on compare les deux
vecteurs d'état quantique π1 et π2, on voit que ce que fait la gate Uf
c'est effectivement de mettre
l'une des deux valeurs, f de 0 ou f de 1, dans l'exposant de moins 1,
ou en d'autres termes, dans
la phase de chaque terme.
C'est la raison pour laquelle
on initialise le qubit du dessous à 1 et on effectue une gate Hadamard dessus pour créer l'état moins,
ce qui permet à cela d'arriver.
C'est ce qu'on appelle le phénomène de phase kickback, et on y reviendra dans quelques instants pour y jeter un autre coup d'œil.
C'est assez important, et on va le voir se produire encore
quelques fois dans la leçon, ainsi que dans les leçons ultérieures.
On peut maintenant simplifier en retirant
l'état moins dehors pour obtenir l'expression
que tu vois ici.
Soit dit en passant, c'est
assez intéressant de noter qu'il n'y a pas vraiment
d'enchevêtrement ici.
Ces deux états sont des états produits. Donc, bien que l'enchevêtrement
soit extrêmement intéressant,
il ne joue
aucun rôle du tout dans cet algorithme particulier.
Nettoyons un peu ça pour avoir un peu plus de place.
Ce qu'on peut maintenant faire c'est
extraire un facteur de moins 1 élevé à la puissance f de zéro
pour obtenir l'expression de l'
état que tu vois ici.
Tu remarqueras que juste là, on a le OU exclusif de f 0 et f 1 dans l'exposant de moins 1.
On pourrait s'attendre à ce que ce soit
f de 1 moins f de 0 parce qu'on a extrait le facteur de moins 1 à la puissance f de 0,
mais on obtient la même
valeur si on prend le XOR parce que ce sont des bits, et la seule chose qui compte quand on a un entier dans
l'exposant de moins 1
c'est si cet entier est pair ou impair.
Une autre façon d'exprimer cet
état est comme on a ici, où on considère simplement
les deux cas possibles pour le XOR.
et c'est une façon commode
d'exprimer l'état quand on considère l'action
de la gate Hadamard finale avec la mesure.
Quand on effectue la dernière
gate Hadamard sur le qubit du dessus, l'état plus est
transformé en un état 0
et l'état moins est
transformé en un état 1, qu'on peut écrire de façon plus
succincte comme ça.
Et enfin, quand la
mesure est effectuée, le résultat qu'on obtient est
donc le XOR de f 0 et f 1,
ce qui est la valeur qu'on cherche, et c'est comme ça que l'algorithme de Deutsch fonctionne.
C'est assez simple, et si on se demande ce qui
le fait fonctionner, ce qui nous permet de calculer
la parité de deux bits
avec une seule requête plutôt que deux, une réponse raisonnable est
que c'est l'interférence.
On calcule effectivement
f de 0 et f de 1 en même temps, parce qu'on a d'abord effectué
la gate Hadamard
sur le qubit du dessus pour mettre l'entrée de f dans
une superposition de 0 et 1.
Et par le biais du phase kickback avec la gate Hadamard finale, on crée essentiellement une interférence constructive
pour la bonne réponse et une interférence destructive
pour la mauvaise réponse.
Donc on ne voit pas la mauvaise réponse, on voit seulement la bonne réponse.
Laisse-moi maintenant dire un peu plus sur le phénomène de phase kickback juste pour le voir sous
un angle légèrement différent.
D'abord, observons
cette formule très simple où b et c sont des valeurs binaires arbitraires.
En bref, XORer un bit b par la valeur 1 est la même chose que d'effectuer une gate NOT ou une opération x sur b,
et bien sûr, explorer
un bit b par la valeur 0 ne fait rien, ce qui est la même chose que d'effectuer l'opération
identité dessus.
Et on peut exprimer l'opération identité comme x à la puissance 0.
Donc si on effectue une gate Uf sur deux qubit dans l'état de base standard ket b tensoriel ket a,
on obtient ce résultat, juste par la définition de la gate Uf.
WEBVTT
et en utilisant la formule, on peut alternativement écrire cet état comme tu le vois ici.
Cette formule fonctionne pour tous les choix de b, donc par linéarité, elle fonctionne
pour un état arbitraire SI
à la place de ket b.
Et en particulier, si on le veut, on peut choisir SI comme étant l'état moins.
Et voici la clé pour comprendre pourquoi le phénomène de phase kickback
se produit.
C'est parce que l'opération x
appliquée à l'état moins nous donne moins 1 fois l'état moins.
En termes mathématiques, on dit que l'état moins
est un vecteur propre de l'opération x, avec une valeur propre égale à moins 1.
Les vecteurs propres et valeurs propres
sont d'une importance capitale en algèbre linéaire ainsi
qu'en information quantique, et on aura beaucoup
plus à dire à leur sujet
à mesure que la série continue.
Mais pour l'instant, tout ce dont on a besoin
c'est cette simple formule.
Et en l'utilisant, on peut
simplifier notre vecteur d'état.
Et ça là c'est essentiellement le phénomène de
phase kickback écrit comme une formule.
Ça fonctionne parce que l'état moins
est un vecteur propre de l'opération NOT ayant
la valeur propre moins un.
On va généraliser ça de façon assez
importante dans la Leçon 7, quand on se tournera vers la procédure d'estimation de
phase, qui est ce qui propulse
l'algorithme de factorisation de Shor.
On peut voir cette formule en action dans l'analyse de l'algorithme de Deutsch
comme suit.
Avant la gate de requête, notre état est le produit tensoriel des états moins et plus.
On applique ensuite la gate de requête, et développer l'état
plus nous donne cet état.
On applique maintenant la formule de phase kickback pour obtenir cette expression, et ensuite l'analyse
continue comme avant.
C'est la même chose qu'avant, mais ici on met simplement
l'accent sur le phase kickback pour qu'on puisse le reconnaître
et qu'on puisse aussi être prêts pour
lui quand il apparaît à nouveau.
Ensuite on va passer à
l'algorithme Deutsch-Jozsa, qui est une extension
de l'algorithme de Deutsch qui résout en fait quelques
problèmes à requêtes différents.
L'avantage que
l'algorithme de Deutsch offre par rapport aux algorithmes classiques
est assez modeste, une requête contre deux.
L'algorithme Deutsch-Jozsa augmente quelque peu cet avantage, et je vais expliquer ce que je veux dire
par là quand on y arrivera.
L'algorithme Deutsch-Jozsa peut être vu comme une façon naturelle et directe d'étendre l'algorithme de Deutsch
des fonctions de un bit à un bit aux fonctions de n bits à un bit, ou en d'autres termes, des fonctions de cette forme.
En tant que circuit quantique, l'algorithme
Deutsch-Jozsa ressemble à ça, et je vais l'appeler
le circuit Deutsch-Jozsa
juste pour établir une légère
distinction entre ce circuit et l'algorithme Deutsch-Jozsa lui-même parce qu'il y a aussi une étape de
post-traitement classique.
L'idée est que si on exécute
ce circuit puis qu'on mesure, on va obtenir une certaine chaîne de n bits y
qui nous dit quelque chose
sur la fonction f.
À ce stade, au passage, je n'ai pas encore dit
quel est le problème à requêtes qu'on pourrait espérer résoudre avec ce circuit, ça vient très bientôt.
Mais le point est qu'en
exécutant ce circuit, on va acquérir des informations sur f qui peuvent potentiellement nous aider
à résoudre des problèmes à requêtes
où f est l'entrée. Et comme je l'ai dit il y a un moment, on peut en fait utiliser ce circuit
pour résoudre quelques
problèmes à requêtes différents.
D'abord, regardons
le problème à requêtes connu sous le nom de problème Deutsch-Jozsa, qui est le problème que
le circuit Deutsch-Jozsa
était originellement destiné à résoudre.
Le problème Deutsch-Jozsa est une généralisation du problème de Deutsch, où le but est de déterminer si une fonction donnée
est constante ou équilibrée.
Remarque que ce n'est pas la façon naturelle de généraliser le problème de parité
aux fonctions de cette forme.
Ici, on ne calcule pas la parité, la tâche est de produire 0 si
la fonction f est constante
et 1 si la fonction f est équilibrée.
La première chose à remarquer à propos de
ce problème est que quand n, le nombre de bits d'entrée de
la fonction f, est au moins 2,
il y a des choix pour la fonction qui ne sont ni constantes ni équilibrées.
Par exemple, voici une
fonction de 2 bits à 1 bit qui n'est ni constante ni équilibrée.
Elle n'est pas constante parce que les deux valeurs binaires
apparaissent parmi les sorties, et elle n'est pas équilibrée
parce que les deux valeurs de sortie
apparaissent avec des fréquences différentes. 0 apparaît trois fois
et 1 n'apparaît qu'une fois.
Pour être équilibrée,
les sorties 0 et 1 doivent se produire exactement
le même nombre de fois.
Le fait qu'il y ait des fonctions qui ne sont ni constantes ni équilibrées quand n est au moins 2 est acceptable cependant, on va juste considérer
des fonctions comme ça
comme des entrées « don't care ». Donc en d'autres termes, c'est
un problème avec promesse.
Et voici un énoncé précis
du problème.
WEBVTT
On nous promet que la fonction d'entrée f est soit constante soit équilibrée, et le but est de déterminer
laquelle c'est.
Et on n'est pas responsable de ce qui se passe si l'entrée
ne satisfait pas la promesse.
L'algorithme Deutsch-Jozsa,
qui résout ce problème, consiste d'abord à exécuter le circuit Deutsch-Jozsa puis à produire 0
si la chaîne qu'on
obtient des mesures est la chaîne tout-zéro
et à produire 1 sinon.
Une autre façon de dire ça c'est qu'on produit le OU des
bits qu'on mesure.
Pour analyser l'algorithme Deutsch-Jozsa, il sera utile de
prendre quelques instants pour réfléchir aux gate Hadamard.
On peut, bien sûr, décrire l'opération Hadamard
comme une matrice, mais on peut aussi la décrire
en termes de son action
sur les états de la base standard,
comme tu le vois ici.
Ces deux équations peuvent être
combinées en une seule équation, qui décrit comment une
opération Hadamard fonctionne pour a étant l'une ou l'autre des
deux valeurs binaires,
et on peut aller un peu plus loin et exprimer ce qu'on
obtient comme une somme comme ça.
En utilisant cette formule, on peut trouver une formule qui décrit comment une couche
de gate Hadamard fonctionne, où on applique une gate Hadamard
à chacun des n qubit.
Ici on décrit cette
action sur les états de base standard.
Et pour être clair sur la notation, quand on écrit h tensoriel n comme ça, où la partie tensoriel n est un exposant,
ce qu'on veut dire c'est le produit tensoriel de H avec lui-même n fois, ou en d'autres termes, n copies
de h toutes tensorielles ensemble.
On applique cette opération
à un état de base standard, et ici je suis la
convention que Qiskit utilise
pour indexer les chaînes binaires, juste parce que c'est le bon moment
pour introduire cette convention.
Donc x0 est un bit, x1 est un bit,
et ainsi de suite avec n bits au total, et les bits sont ordonnés comme
tu le vois ici à l'écran.
Tu peux penser à cette
façon d'indexer les bits comme correspondant à leur signification si on voit les chaînes comme
représentant des entiers
en notation binaire, par exemple.
Si on applique une gate Hadamard
à chacun de ces qubit, on peut alternativement exprimer le résultat comme le produit tensoriel n fois
d'une gate Hadamard appliquée à chaque qubit, et on peut ensuite appliquer notre formule à chacun des facteurs tensoriels.
Et ici on utilise les
noms y et moins 1 jusqu'à y1 à la place de b dans la formule,
donc ce sont des valeurs binaires. Et on s'assure d'utiliser un nouveau nom à chaque fois qu'on utilise la formule.
Si on développe alors tout en utilisant la multilinéarité
des produits tensoriels, on obtient l'expression
que tu vois ici.
Et pour être clair, les n sommes sont
combinées en une seule somme, mais on somme toujours
sur toutes les valeurs possibles
pour les valeurs binaires individuelles.
Maintenant nettoyons les choses pour pouvoir aller un peu plus loin.
Et l'étape suivante consiste à
introduire une nouvelle opération sur les chaînes appelée le produit scalaire binaire.
C'est une opération sur des chaînes binaires de même longueur.
Et le produit scalaire binaire de deux chaînes x et y
de même longueur est le OU exclusif ou la parité
des produits des bits individuels.
On pourrait aussi dire que c'est le XOR du ET logique des bits individuels, parce que le ET est la même chose que le produit
pour les valeurs binaires. Encore une autre façon de le décrire
c'est que c'est 1 ou 0
selon que
la somme des produits des bits individuels est impaire ou paire.
C'est très semblable à un produit scalaire si on pense aux chaînes
comme des vecteurs de valeurs binaires, mais où on calcule modulo-2,
ou en d'autres termes, on prend le reste après division par 2.
Ce n'est pas vraiment un produit scalaire cependant, donc il mérite un nom différent.
Dans le cas présent, on peut utiliser le produit scalaire binaire
pour rendre notre formule pour l'action d'une couche de gate Hadamard
sur les états de base standard plus succincte, et la voici ici.
On utilise le fait que
parce que cette somme ici apparaît dans l'exposant de moins 1,
tout ce qui compte c'est si
elle est paire ou impaire, mais autrement, c'est essentiellement juste une version condensée
de notre formule.
Au passage, le produit scalaire binaire
est symétrique dans le sens que x point
y et y point x sont égaux,
donc on est libre de permuter
l'ordre quand c'est utile.
Et maintenant qu'on a cette formule, ce sera assez facile d'analyser
le circuit Deutsch-Jozsa.
On commence avec n qubit dans l'état 0 et le qubit du dessous dans l'état 1, et on effectue des gate Hadamard
sur tous.
Donc c'est l'état des
n + 1 qubit qu'on obtient.
On traite le
qubit du dessous séparément parce que ça va être pratique.
Et encore une fois, on va voir le phénomène de phase kickback
se produire.
WEBVTT
On peut obtenir cette expression
en utilisant notre formule, où on substitue la chaîne tout-zéro pour x et on substitue x pour y,
en notant que le produit scalaire
binaire de la chaîne tout-zéro avec n'importe quelle chaîne est 0.
Mais on peut aussi raisonner directement. On prend le produit tensoriel de n états plus, et c'est ce qu'on obtient,
tensoriel à l'état moins. Ensuite la gate UF est appliquée, et c'est là que le phénomène de
phase kickback se produit.
La valeur f de x est XORée
sur l'état moins pour chaque x dans la somme.
Donc f de x est kické dans la phase.
On applique maintenant une autre
couche de gate Hadamard juste aux n qubit du dessus, et cette fois, on a vraiment
besoin de la formule.
Et quand on l'applique et qu'on fait un peu
de simplification, on obtient cet état ici.
Donc c'est notre état final juste
avant les mesures.
L'état semble un peu compliqué, et il est difficile de le simplifier parce qu'on ne sait pas vraiment
grand chose de la fonction f.
Mais rappelle-toi, que tout
ce qu'on a vraiment besoin de savoir c'est si toutes les mesures
ou non donnent le résultat 0,
parce que c'est ça qui détermine quelle est notre réponse au problème.
Si on voit que chaque
résultat de mesure est 0, on conclut que la fonction est constante.
Et si l'un
des résultats de mesure est 1, on conclut que la fonction est équilibrée.
Donc calculons la probabilité d'obtenir la chaîne tout-zéro
des mesures.
Et il s'avère que c'est le seul résultat qui est en fait facile à calculer, parce que le produit scalaire binaire de la chaîne tout-zéro
avec n'importe quelle chaîne est zéro. Si on examine notre vecteur et
on réfléchit à ce qui se passe quand y est la chaîne tout-zéro,
on obtient cette expression ici
pour la probabilité d'obtenir la chaîne tout-zéro
des mesures.
Et en considérant les deux cas possibles où f est constante et f est équilibrée, on voit que la probabilité d'obtenir la chaîne tout-zéro est 1
dans le cas où f est constante, et zéro quand f est équilibrée.
Quand f est constante, la somme est soit 2 à la
n soit moins 2 à la n, et en divisant par 2 à la n
et en prenant la valeur absolue
au carré, on obtient 1.
Et quand f est équilibrée, la somme est égale à 0.
C'est parce qu'on va obtenir
plus 1 et moins 1 le même nombre de fois,
donc ils s'annulent tous.
Voilà. L'algorithme Deutsch-Jozsa
résout le problème Deutsch-Jozsa en utilisant une seule requête,
et il n'y a pas d'erreur. En supposant que les opérations
sont toutes effectuées parfaitement, il est correct à chaque fois.
Alors comment ça se compare avec
ce qu'on peut faire classiquement ?
Eh bien, si on insiste sur un algorithme
déterministe qui obtient la réponse
correcte à chaque fois, alors dans le pire des cas,
on a besoin de 2 à la n moins 1 plus 1 requêtes, et c'est parce qu'on doit
interroger la fonction
sur plus de la moitié de ses entrées pour être sûr de la solution.
Même si on interroge la fonction sur 2 à la n moins 1
différentes chaînes d'entrée, il est possible qu'on verra la même valeur de sortie
à chaque fois, et ça pourrait être parce que
la fonction est constante, ou il se pourrait qu'elle soit en fait équilibrée
et qu'on ait juste eu incroyablement malchance en voyant la même valeur de sortie
à chaque fois.
Donc c'est un énorme avantage
du quantique sur le classique, une seule requête contre
un nombre exponentiellement grand de requêtes.
Cependant, si on utilise un
algorithme à requêtes probabiliste et qu'on accepte une petite probabilité qu'il réponde incorrectement,
alors on n'a réellement besoin que de quelques requêtes.
En particulier, si on
choisit aléatoirement k chaînes et qu'on évalue la fonction
sur ces chaînes aléatoires,
alors on est assez susceptible de pouvoir déterminer la bonne réponse.
Plus précisément, on répond 0 ou constant quand on obtient la même valeur de fonction à chaque fois et 1 ou équilibré
quand on voit deux
valeurs de fonction différentes.
Si on fait ça, on aura toujours raison quand
la fonction est constante parce que, bien sûr, on verra toujours la même
valeur de sortie dans ce cas.
Et si f est équilibrée, on est très susceptible de voir
deux valeurs de sortie différentes.
La chance qu'on ne voit pas
les deux valeurs de sortie dans ce cas est la même que la chance qu'on a de lancer une pièce k fois
et d'obtenir le même
résultat à chaque fois.
Donc par exemple, si on
fixe k à 11, la probabilité d'obtenir une mauvaise réponse est inférieure à un dixième de pour cent.
Donc surtout quand on considère le fait que les ordinateurs quantiques ne seront jamais parfaits en réalité, on n'obtient pas vraiment un si
grand avantage ici,
mais on fait des progrès, et on a un avantage quantifiable du quantique sur le classique qui va au-delà de l'algorithme de Deutsch.
On peut aussi utiliser le circuit Deutsch-Jozsa pour résoudre un problème à requêtes différent connu sous le nom de problème de Bernstein-Vazirani.
Voici un énoncé de ce problème. L'entrée est une fonction
de n bits à 1 bit, tout comme le problème Deutsch-Jozsa,
WEBVTT
et encore une fois, c'est un problème avec promesse.
Cette fois, la promesse est qu'il existe une certaine chaîne de n bits s pour laquelle la fonction f
fonctionne comme tu le vois ici,
où la sortie est donnée
par le produit scalaire binaire de l'entrée avec cette chaîne s,
et le but est simplement
de trouver la chaîne s. Donc on peut imaginer que la
chaîne s est cachée dans un certain sens,
mais on peut en apprendre à son sujet
en effectuant des requêtes à f, et notre objectif est de trouver
cette chaîne cachée.
Pour être clair, la plupart des fonctions
ne satisfont pas cette promesse, mais comme d'habitude, on ne se préoccupe que des
fonctions d'entrée qui le font.
Il s'avère que le circuit Deutsch-Jozsa résout en fait ce problème
directement.
Si on l'exécute pour une
fonction comme on en a une ici qui satisfait la
promesse pour une certaine chaîne s, les mesures vont révéler la chaîne s
sans post-traitement requis.
Alors voyons comment ça fonctionne.
On a déjà analysé
le circuit Deutsch-Jozsa, donc on peut en fait juste
aller directement à la fin.
Voici l'expression qu'on
avait de tout à l'heure pour l'état juste avant les mesures, et cette expression était
valide pour n'importe quelle fonction f.
Et maintenant, si on substitue
ce qu'on nous promet sur la fonction f et qu'on simplifie,
on obtient l'état moins
pour le qubit du dessous tensoriel avec ket s pour les n qubit du dessus.
Et donc on obtient s quand on mesure.
Il y a quelques calculs à faire pour effectuer les simplifications
que j'ai montrées ici, et je n'en ferai pas la démonstration dans cette vidéo,
mais il y a plus de détails à ce sujet dans le contenu du manuel pour cette série, que tu peux trouver en suivant le lien dans la description de la vidéo,
ou essaie juste toi-même
pour t'entraîner.
Donc ce qu'on a trouvé c'est que
le circuit Deutsch-Jozsa résout le problème de Bernstein-Vazirani
avec une seule requête.
Il n'est pas trop difficile de montrer
que tout algorithme classique, qu'il soit déterministe
ou probabiliste, a besoin d'au moins n requêtes
pour résoudre le problème de Bernstein-Vazirani pour la simple raison qu'on a besoin de n bits d'information
pour récupérer s,
et chaque requête nous donne au
plus 1 bit d'information.
Donc on obtient un autre avantage du quantique sur les algorithmes à requêtes
classiques, une requête pour les algorithmes quantiques,
n requêtes pour les algorithmes classiques.
Cela vaut la peine de prendre juste un moment pour parler de la
nomenclature utilisée dans le contexte de ce problème et un peu de son histoire.
Les gens font parfois référence à l'algorithme que je viens de décrire comme étant l'algorithme de Bernstein-Vazirani, mais c'est vraiment juste le
circuit Deutsch-Jozsa,
et c'est quelque chose qui était,
en fait, très clairement énoncé dans le travail de Bernstein et Vazirani.
Donc c'est un peu étrange que ça soit appelé l'algorithme de
Bernstein-Vazirani parce que c'est à peu près la même chose que l'algorithme Deutsch-Jozsa
moins le post-traitement. Bernstein et Vazirani ont cependant
fait un pas de plus.
Ils ont défini une version récursive
de ce problème, où tu dois essentiellement
résoudre des instances du problème de Bernstein-Vazirani
pour débloquer de nouvelles instances du problème qui sont arrangées dans un
schéma arborescent complexe.
C'est un problème très artificiel, mais le point est qu'en
définissant un problème de cette façon, ils pouvaient effectivement étendre
la séparation une requête contre n requêtes entre quantique et classique.
Et ce qu'ils ont obtenu c'est
le tout premier exemple connu d'un avantage dit super-polynomial du quantique sur les algorithmes probabilistes.
Cette version récursive du
problème de Bernstein-Vazirani s'est aussi révélée beaucoup plus tard
très intéressante en théorie de la complexité computationnelle pour différentes raisons.
Quoi qu'il en soit, le point est que
Bernstein et Vazirani méritent certainement d'être reconnus pour leurs importantes contributions,
mais il n'est vraiment pas logique
de qualifier cela d'algorithme de Bernstein-Vazirani, c'est fondamentalement juste l'algorithme
Deutsch-Jozsa.
Dans la dernière partie de la leçon, on va voir un
autre algorithme à requêtes quantique connu sous le nom de l'algorithme de Simon.
Tu verras une claire similitude
entre cet algorithme et l'algorithme Deutsch-Jozsa, mais il est différent, et plus important encore,
il révèle un avantage bien plus fort du quantique sur les algorithmes à requêtes
classiques.
Plus précisément, il nous donne un
avantage exponentiel prouvable du quantique sur les algorithmes classiques, même les probabilistes.
Le problème qu'il résout est un peu artificiel, et il est difficile d'imaginer une situation dans laquelle résoudre ce
problème serait utile,
mais il a directement inspiré
la découverte par Peter Shor d'un algorithme quantique
pour la factorisation des entiers,
et cela soutient très fortement
cette idée du modèle à requêtes comme une boîte de Petri dans laquelle des idées algorithmiques
quantiques peuvent être développées.
Commençons par le problème à requêtes que l'algorithme de Simon résout, qui, comme tu l'as peut-être deviné,
s'appelle le problème de Simon.
Voici un énoncé du problème, et on va devoir le décortiquer pour comprendre de quoi il s'agit.
La première chose à
remarquer c'est que cette fois, la fonction d'entrée f transforme des chaînes de n
bits en chaînes de m bits
où m est un entier positif qui n'est pas nécessairement égal à un.
WEBVTT
C'est un problème avec promesse. Et comme le problème de Bernstein-Vazirani, la promesse implique une certaine chaîne s qu'on peut voir comme étant une chaîne cachée,
et aussi comme le
problème de Bernstein-Vazirani, le but est de produire
cette chaîne cachée s.
La promesse est plus
compliquée cette fois cependant, alors décortiquons-la et
comprenons ce qu'elle dit.
Pour commencer, lisons-la. Il dit qu'il existe une chaîne s de longueur égale à n
telle qu'une condition particulière de « si »
et « seulement si » est vraie pour tous les choix de chaînes de n bits x et y.
Plus précisément, il doit
être le cas que f de x est égal à f de y si et seulement si l'une des
deux possibilités se vérifie.
La première possibilité est que x est égal à y, et la deuxième possibilité est qu'en prenant le
OU exclusif bit à bit de x
avec la chaîne cachée s, on obtient Y.
Il s'avère que c'est une
promesse assez stricte dans le sens que la plupart des
fonctions ne la satisferont pas.
Seules les fonctions très spéciales
satisfont cette condition.
Maintenant, pour mieux saisir cette promesse et donc le problème lui-même, on va considérer deux cas principaux.
Le premier cas est que s
est la chaîne tout-zéro.
Dans ce cas, on peut simplifier l'énoncé « si »
et « seulement si » dans la promesse parce que le
OU exclusif bit à bit de toute chaîne x
avec la chaîne tout-zéro
est simplement la chaîne x.
Donc la condition se simplifie
en f de x est égal à f de y si et seulement si x est égal à y.
Et c'est juste une autre façon de dire que f est une fonction injective.
En d'autres termes, la chaîne f de x doit être unique
pour chaque chaîne possible x.
Donc si f est une fonction injective, alors la promesse est en effet satisfaite, plus précisément pour s étant
la chaîne tout-zéro,
et dans ce cas, c'est
la sortie correcte.
Le deuxième cas est que s
n'est pas la chaîne tout-zéro, et ce que cela implique c'est que la fonction f doit être deux-à-un.
Donc pour chaque chaîne d'entrée x, il y a exactement une autre chaîne que f transforme en la même
chaîne à laquelle x est transformé,
et de plus, l'autre chaîne
doit être la chaîne qu'on obtient en prenant le
OU exclusif bit à bit de x avec s.
Une autre façon de le dire
c'est que chaque chaîne de n bits x a un partenaire, et ce partenaire est la chaîne qu'on obtient
en prenant le OU exclusif bit à bit avec s.
Deux partenaires quelconques doivent nous donner
la même chaîne de sortie si on les passe dans f, et aucune autre chaîne n'est autorisée à nous donner
cette même chaîne de sortie.
Donc ce sont nécessairement des chaînes distinctes que les partenaires produisent.
Voici un exemple d'une fonction comme ça décrite par sa table de valeurs.
Donc c'est une fonction
de 3 bits à 5 bits.
Si on regarde attentivement cette table
de valeurs un moment, on trouve que la promesse est
satisfaite pour la chaîne 011.
000 et 011 sont des partenaires. XORer l'un ou l'autre par s nous donne l'autre,
et ils prennent la même valeur de sortie, qui est 10011 dans ce cas particulier, et aucune autre chaîne ne produit
cette même chaîne de sortie.
001 et 010 sont des partenaires parce que XORer l'un ou l'autre
par s donne l'autre, et ils produisent la même valeur de sortie,
qui encore une fois, n'est produite
par aucune autre chaîne.
Et la situation est
similaire pour 100 et 111 ainsi que 101 et 110.
Donc si l'entrée du
problème est cette fonction, la bonne réponse est la chaîne 011.
Comme je l'ai dit avant, la plupart des fonctions ne satisfont pas cette promesse, c'est une condition très spécifique.
Il faut aussi noter que
si la promesse est satisfaite, elle ne peut être satisfaite que pour une seule chaîne s.
Donc il y a toujours seulement une
bonne réponse à ce problème.
Voilà le problème de Simon. Comme je l'ai dit, il est difficile d'imaginer une situation pratique dans laquelle tu voudrais résoudre ce problème,
mais ce n'est pas le sujet. Le sujet est d'essayer de comprendre ce pour quoi les ordinateurs quantiques sont bons, et il s'avère qu'ils sont bien supérieurs
aux algorithmes classiques pour
résoudre ce problème particulier.
Maintenant voyons
l'algorithme de Simon, qui résout le problème de Simon.
L'algorithme consiste à
exécuter le circuit quantique que tu vois ici plusieurs fois, suivi d'une étape de
post-traitement classique,
et on sera plus précis sur ce que « plusieurs
fois » signifie un peu plus tard.
Le circuit ressemble beaucoup
au circuit Deutsch-Jozsa, cette fois parce que la fonction
f transforme n bits en m bits,
la gate de requête est différente. Plutôt qu'un seul
qubit en bas, on a maintenant m qubit en bas
et n en haut comme avant.
Une différence clé c'est qu'on ne
configure pas un état moins ou plusieurs états moins en bas.
Ces qubit du dessous sont tous
initialisés à l'état 0, et ces états vont directement
dans la gate de requête.
WEBVTT
Donc il n'y aura pas de phase kickback impliqué dans cet algorithme, c'est juste pas comme ça que celui-ci fonctionne.
Hormis les différences
que je viens de mentionner cependant, ça ressemble beaucoup au
circuit Deutsch-Jozsa.
On applique une couche de gate Hadamard, puis on applique une gate de requête une seule fois, et puis on applique une autre
couche de gate Hadamard
suivie de mesures dans la base standard des n qubit du dessus.
L'idée c'est que chaque fois qu'on
exécute ce circuit et qu'on mesure, on va obtenir une certaine chaîne y qui nous dit quelque chose
sur la chaîne cachée s
dans le problème de Simon. Et en exécutant le circuit
plusieurs fois indépendamment, on aura rassemblé suffisamment
de preuves statistiques sur s
pour pouvoir déterminer ce que
c'est avec une grande confiance.
Maintenant analysons le circuit quantique
pour l'algorithme de Simon pour voir ce qu'il fait.
L'état après la première
couche de gate Hadamard ressemble à ça, similaire à ce qu'on avait pour
l'algorithme Deutsch-Jozsa.
Sauf que cette fois, les m qubit du dessous sont tous dans l'état 0
plutôt que dans des états moins.
Après que la gate de requête est effectuée, on voit que la valeur f de x a été écrite sur les
m qubit du dessous ou de gauche,
et c'est parce que f de x a été XORée sur la chaîne tout-zéro.
Donc encore une fois, il n'y a pas de phase kickback se produisant dans cet algorithme.
On effectue ensuite la deuxième
couche de gate Hadamard.
Et en utilisant la même formule qu'avant pour l'action d'une
couche de gate Hadamard sur un état de base
standard, ket x dans ce cas,
comme c'était dans la formule d'origine, on obtient cet état ici, où l'action des gate Hadamard
est rendue plus apparente. Mais si on le veut, on peut aussi écrire l'état
sous une forme plus compacte comme on a ici.
À ce stade, on mesure les n qubit du dessus pour obtenir une certaine chaîne de n bits y, et on a juste besoin de déterminer
quelles sont les probabilités
pour les différentes chaînes. Et ça nous aidera à comprendre
quelle information on obtient de cette chaîne y sur la chaîne s
qui est cachée à l'intérieur de la fonction f.
On va avoir besoin
de plus de place pour ça, et on n'a vraiment plus besoin
du diagramme du circuit, alors débarrassons-nous-en et donnons-nous un peu
de plus d'espace pour l'analyse.
Voici l'état juste
avant les mesures, qui sont des mesures dans la base standard des n qubit du dessus ou de droite.
Donc la mesure
correspond au deuxième ket.
Notons par p de y, la probabilité que les mesures nous donnent la chaîne y pour chaque y possible.
Et si on suit les règles de la Leçon 2, on obtient que chacune de ces probabilités est la norme euclidienne au carré de quel que soit le vecteur qui est tensoriel
à l'état de base standard,
correspondant à y dans
notre vecteur d'état quantique.
Ça nous donne cette expression ici.
Maintenant, pour mieux maîtriser
ces probabilités, on va avoir besoin d'utiliser certaines notations, et tu pourrais déjà
connaître cette notation
parce qu'elle est assez courante en mathématiques.
D'abord, quand on fait référence à l'
image de la fonction f, on veut juste dire l'ensemble de toutes les chaînes qui peuvent sortir de cette fonction.
Donc c'est l'ensemble de tous les f de x variant sur tous les
choix possibles d'une chaîne d'entrée x.
Ensuite, on va utiliser cette notation que tu vois ici pour désigner l'ensemble de toutes les chaînes d'entrée x
que f transforme en une chaîne z donnée, pour n'importe quel choix de
z qu'on veut considérer.
Ça ressemble un peu à
l'inverse de la fonction f, mais ce n'est pas vraiment l'inverse parce que f n'est pas nécessairement inversible.
On voit aussi qu'on a
un ensemble comme argument du côté gauche, et dans ce cas, c'est l'ensemble contenant
juste une seule chaîne z,
et c'est l'indice dont on a besoin pour reconnaître qu'on ne parle pas de
l'inverse de la fonction f, cela s'appelle la pré-image.
La pré-image peut être
définie plus généralement pour n'importe quel ensemble donné comme argument, pas seulement l'ensemble contenant
un seul élément,
mais c'est tout ce dont on va avoir besoin. Ce n'est pas la meilleure
notation au monde parce qu'il est facile de
la confondre avec l'inverse,
mais elle est assez claire
et largement utilisée, donc on va s'en tenir à elle.
Et maintenant si on utilise cette notation, on peut réécrire le vecteur dont on prend la norme euclidienne au carré pour obtenir la probabilité de
mesurer chaque chaîne y.
On fait ça parce qu'on a besoin de voir
quels sont les coefficients pour chaque état de base standard individuel, et ça n'est pas clair de
cette expression ici,
parce qu'en général, on peut
avoir plusieurs choix de x nous donnant la même chaîne f de x.
En essence, tout ce qu'on fait
c'est de décomposer la somme sur x en commençant par sommer sur tous
z dans l'image de f,
et puis à l'intérieur de cette somme, sommer sur tous x dans la pré-image de z, ou pour être plus précis,
la pré-image de l'ensemble
contenant la chaîne z.
Ça nous permet de remplacer f de x par z à l'intérieur du ket ici.
Et la somme sur toutes les différentes chaînes
x que f transforme en chaque z est collectée dans le
coefficient pour chaque ket.
On met essentiellement les chaînes dans des bacs, on somme sur les bacs, et puis on somme sur
les chaînes dans chaque bac,
WEBVTT
mais c'est équivalent à simplement
sommer sur toutes les chaînes.
Donc on obtient bien une expression qui est équivalente à
celle avec laquelle on a commencé,
et maintenant on peut calculer la
norme euclidienne au carré.
C'est juste la somme des carrés des valeurs absolues
des coefficients, et donc on obtient cette expression ici
pour nos probabilités.
Bien sûr, prends le temps de vérifier ça, si tu choisis de le faire, ça prend du temps pour s'habituer à tout ça
et pour être en mesure d'effectuer
ces calculs, et plus tu t'exerces, plus ce sera facile.
Jusqu'à présent, on n'a en fait pas
du tout utilisé la promesse dans le problème de Simon.
Notre analyse de ces probabilités fonctionne en fait pour n'importe quelle fonction f, mais maintenant il est temps de réfléchir au problème de Simon
spécifiquement.
On va décomposer les choses dans les deux mêmes cas
qu'on avait avant.
Le premier cas est que s
est la chaîne tout-zéro, et le deuxième cas est que
s n'est pas la chaîne tout-zéro.
Dans le premier cas, que
s est la chaîne tout-zéro, les choses sont assez simples.
Dans ce cas, comme on l'a vu avant, on a que f est une fonction injective, donc il y a une seule chaîne x
qui est transformée en chacune des
chaînes z dans l'image de f.
Ça rend la valeur absolue au carré de la somme sur ces chaînes égale à 1 parce qu'il y a juste un
seul terme dans la somme,
c'est soit plus 1 soit moins 1, mais ça n'a pas d'importance lequel parce qu'on prend la
valeur absolue au carré, et donc on obtient un.
Il y a 2 à la n
éléments dans l'image de f, et on le sait parce que f est injective, donc il y a une chaîne dans l'image
pour chaque chaîne d'entrée.
Et si on évalue l'expression entière, on trouve que chaque chaîne y apparaît avec une probabilité
d'un sur deux à la n.
Donc en d'autres termes, les
mesures nous donnent une chaîne y choisie uniformément au hasard.
Ça peut ne pas sembler très utile, mais on sera en fait capable
de distinguer ce comportement du comportement qu'on obtient dans le cas
où s n'est pas la chaîne tout-zéro, et on verra comment ça se passe prochainement.
Pour l'instant cependant, on observe simplement que si
f satisfait la promesse dans le problème de Simon dans le cas où s est la chaîne tout-zéro,
alors le résultat des mesures est une chaîne aléatoire uniforme.
Maintenant passons au deuxième cas, qui est que la promesse
est satisfaite pour une chaîne s qui n'est pas la chaîne tout-zéro.
Dans ce cas, comme on en a discuté avant, chaque chaîne z dans l'image de f a exactement deux chaînes qui s'y transforment,
parce que chaque chaîne a un partenaire, et chaque paire de partenaires
s'applique à une chaîne unique, et plus précisément, le partenaire de chaque chaîne
est la chaîne qu'on obtient en XORant avec s.
Donc si on choisit n'importe quelle chaîne
z dans l'image de f, et qu'on donne le nom w à l'une ou l'autre des
chaînes que f transforme en z,
alors le XOR de w avec s est la
autre chaîne qui s'applique à z.
En regardant juste le terme dans notre somme qui correspond à quelle que soit la chaîne z dans l'image qu'on a en tête,
on voit qu'on peut
l'écrire plus explicitement comme on a ici.
On a deux chaînes dans la pré-image de z, w et w XORé avec s.
Donc on peut écrire la somme
comme tu le vois à l'écran, et maintenant ce qu'on peut faire c'est extraire un facteur de
moins 1 à la puissance w.y.
Ce facteur va être
soit plus 1 soit moins 1, donc il disparaît quand on
prend la valeur absolue,
et ce avec quoi on se retrouve c'est
cette expression ici.
Les détails ne sont pas tous montrés ici, et ce n'est pas nécessairement
évident que ça fonctionne comme ça, mais tu peux vérifier que ces
deux expressions sont égales
en revenant à la définition
du produit scalaire binaire et en réfléchissant à ce qui se passe quand ces choses sont dans
l'exposant de moins 1,
pas sans ressemblance à ce qu'on avait pour le
problème de Bernstein-Vazirani.
Enfin, on peut décomposer cette
expression en deux cas.
C'est 4 quand le produit scalaire binaire
de s et y est 0, et c'est 0 quand le produit scalaire
binaire de s et y est 1.
Remarque en particulier qu'il n'y a aucune dépendance ici sur w ou z, ça ne dépend que de s et y.
La raison pour laquelle ça arrive c'est
à cause de la nature très spécifique et particulière de la promesse.
En essence, c'est pourquoi la promesse a été formulée de cette façon, pour que tout se passe comme ça.
Encore une fois, chaque chaîne a un partenaire, qu'on obtient en XORant avec
cette seule chaîne cachée s,
et c'est ce qui fait que tout ça arrive.
On peut maintenant revenir à l'
expression pour les probabilités et substituer.
Quand s n'est pas la chaîne tout-zéro, il y a 2 à la n moins 1
éléments dans l'image de f,
ce qui est la moitié du
nombre de chaînes d'entrée, et substituer les
valeurs qu'on vient de calculer donne cette formule ici.
Donc cette fois, y n'est pas une
chaîne complètement aléatoire, mais plutôt y est uniforme sur exactement la moitié des chaînes de n bits,
WEBVTT
et plus précisément, elle est
uniforme sur les chaînes qui ont un produit scalaire binaire égal à 0 avec s.
Maintenant qu'on sait comment le circuit
pour l'algorithme de Simon fonctionne et plus précisément quelles
sont les probabilités pour les différents résultats de mesure,
il reste à expliquer comment cela nous aide à résoudre le problème de Simon.
En résumant ce qu'on vient d'apprendre, si la fonction f satisfait la promesse dans le problème de Simon,
quand la chaîne cachée s
est la chaîne tout-zéro, on obtient une chaîne complètement aléatoire des mesures,
où chaque chaîne de n bits
y est également probable.
Si d'un autre côté, la fonction f satisfait la promesse pour une chaîne s différente, une qui n'est pas égale
à la chaîne tout-zéro,
alors on obtient une chaîne aléatoire y ayant un produit scalaire binaire
égal à 0 avec s, et parmi toutes ces chaînes,
chaque y est également probable.
Mais on n'obtiendra jamais une chaîne y ayant un produit scalaire binaire
égal à 1 avec s.
La question devient : « Est-ce que c'est suffisant d'informations
pour déterminer s ? » Et la réponse, comme je l'ai
déjà suggéré, est oui,
à condition qu'on exécute le
circuit suffisamment de fois.
Plus précisément, supposons
qu'on exécute le circuit k fois, où K est égal à n plus r,
où r est un nombre qui va contrôler la
probabilité qu'on récupère s.
Juste à titre d'exemple, si
on choisit r à 10, on réussira avec
une probabilité supérieure à 99,9 %,
donc on n'a pas besoin que r soit très grand.
En général, la probabilité d'échec est inférieure à la probabilité
de lancer une pièce équilibrée r fois et d'obtenir face à chaque fois.
Donc si 99,9 % n'est pas assez bien,
prends r à 20, et la chance d'échec est
inférieure à une sur un million,
ou choisis n'importe quel r
qui te convient. Tu ne peux pas garantir une solution correcte, mais tu peux rendre la
probabilité d'erreur négligeable
à toutes fins pratiques.
Ici on nomme ces
chaînes y1 jusqu'à yk, où on utilise des exposants pour nous aider à nommer ces chaînes,
juste pour qu'on puisse réserver les indices pour faire référence aux bits individuels
de ces chaînes.
Donc ce ne sont pas des exposants
ou quoi que ce soit comme ça, ce sont juste les noms qu'on donne à ces k chaînes.
Chacune a une longueur n parce qu'on les a obtenues
en exécutant le circuit pour l'algorithme de Simon.
Donc on peut écrire les
bits individuels de ces k chaînes comme tu le vois ici.
Ce qu'on fait maintenant c'est de créer une matrice m, où chaque entrée de cette matrice est un bit, et on obtient ces bits des chaînes
qu'on vient de mesurer, exactement comme montré ici.
Donc cette matrice a k lignes et n colonnes, et ses entrées sont toutes des valeurs binaires.
Maintenant, on ne sait pas ce qu'est s. C'est ce qu'on essaie de trouver, mais imagine juste
un moment qu'on le savait,
et on formait un vecteur colonne
à partir des bits de s, exactement comme montré ici.
Si on multipliait ce vecteur par m et qu'on prenait ensuite le résultat modulo-2, ou une autre façon de dire ça
c'est qu'on remplace l'addition
par le OU exclusif, alors on obtiendra nécessairement
le vecteur tout-zéro.
C'est parce que chacune des
entrées dans ce vecteur résultant n'est rien d'autre que le
produit scalaire binaire de s
avec l'une des lignes de m.
Si S est la chaîne tout-zéro, on obtiendra toujours le vecteur zéro du produit scalaire binaire.
Et si s n'est pas la chaîne tout-zéro, on l'obtient de ce qu'on
sait sur les probabilités pour les chaînes y1 jusqu'à yk d'apparaître.
En particulier, le
produit scalaire binaire avec s est toujours zéro pour toutes ces chaînes.
Une façon simple de dire ça c'est que ce vecteur
formé à partir des bits de s est toujours dans le noyau de la matrice m,
en supposant qu'on fait toute notre
arithmétique modulo-2, mais bien sûr, on ne sait pas ce qu'est s,
on essaie de trouver s.
Mais ce qu'on peut faire c'est qu'on peut calculer le
noyau de cette matrice m, encore une fois, modulo-2.
Plus précisément, on peut le faire en utilisant la technique de l'élimination
de Gauss, qui est la procédure souvent enseignée
dans les cours d'introduction à l'algèbre linéaire.
Elle fonctionne parfaitement bien quand on fait toute notre arithmétique modulo-2, et elle peut être effectuée assez
efficacement avec un ordinateur.
Et si on calcule le noyau de m, étant donné la façon spécifique dont ces k chaînes ont
été choisies aléatoirement,
on sera en mesure de récupérer s avec une probabilité supérieure à
1 moins 2 à la puissance moins r.
Pour être précis, ce qu'on verra avec une probabilité supérieure à
1 moins 2 à la puissance moins r c'est que le noyau
contient le vecteur tout-zéro,
comme c'est toujours le cas pour chaque matrice, ainsi que le vecteur correspondant à s, qu'il soit le vecteur tout-zéro ou non.
Et surtout, aucun autre vecteur n'apparaîtra
dans le noyau.
Ce n'est en fait pas trop difficile à prouver, bien que je n'en donne pas les détails.
WEBVTT
L'idée c'est que si on
a une autre chaîne qui n'est pas le vecteur tout-zéro
et ce n'est pas s, alors chacune des chaînes aléatoires, y1 jusqu'à yk,
va essentiellement la
sortir du noyau avec une probabilité d'un demi.
Donc après k essais, elle n'a
aucune chance de survivre, et en fait, aucune des
chaînes qui n'y appartiennent pas
n'est susceptible de survivre. Et un fait très simple
de la théorie des probabilités, connu sous le nom de borne d'union, peut
être utilisé pour établir ça.
Je n'ai pas expliqué tous
les détails ici, mais j'espère que tu comprends l'idée qu'en calculant le noyau
modulo-2 de cette matrice m,
on est très susceptible de récupérer s, et c'est comme ça que l'algorithme de Simon
résout le problème de Simon.
Il ne reste qu'une chose
à dire sur le problème de Simon, et cela concerne la
difficulté classique de ce problème,
c'est-à-dire combien de requêtes un algorithme à requêtes classique a-t-il besoin pour résoudre le problème de Simon ?
La réponse c'est beaucoup, en général.
Il y a différents énoncés précis
qui peuvent être faits sur la
difficulté classique de ce problème, et en voici juste un.
Si on a n'importe quel algorithme à requêtes
probabiliste et que cet algorithme effectue moins de 2 à la puissance n sur 2
moins 1, moins 1 requêtes,
donc c'est un nombre de requêtes
qui est exponentiel en n, alors cet algorithme échouera
à résoudre le problème de Simon,
avec une probabilité d'au moins un demi.
Parfois, prouver des
résultats d'impossibilité comme celui-ci peut être très difficile, mais celui-ci n'est pas trop difficile à prouver
par une analyse probabiliste
élémentaire.
Je ne vais pas faire ça dans cette leçon vidéo, et je vais plutôt me concentrer
sur l'intuition derrière ça.
On essaie de trouver la chaîne cachée s, mais tant qu'on n'interroge pas la fonction sur deux chaînes ayant
la même valeur de sortie,
on obtiendra très peu
d'informations sur s.
En gros, tout ce qu'on apprend c'est
que la chaîne cachée s n'est pas le OU exclusif de deux chaînes distinctes quelconques
qu'on a interrogées,
Et si on interroge la fonction avec moins que ce nombre de requêtes, il y aura encore beaucoup de choix de s
qui n'ont pas été écartés.
Ce n'est pas une preuve formelle,
mais c'est l'idée de base.
Donc en résumé, l'algorithme de Simon nous fournit un avantage frappant du quantique sur les algorithmes classiques
dans le cadre du modèle à requêtes.
En particulier, l'algorithme de Simon
résout le problème de Simon avec un nombre de requêtes qui est linéaire dans le nombre de bits d'entrée
n de notre fonction,
tandis que tout algorithme classique,
même s'il est probabiliste, doit effectuer un nombre de
requêtes qui est exponentiel en n
pour résoudre le problème de Simon avec une probabilité de succès raisonnable.
Il est vrai que le problème de Simon est un problème quelque peu artificiel que vraisemblablement personne
ne veut vraiment résoudre,
mais c'est secondaire. Parfois les idées doivent être développées avant d'être mises en pratique.
Et en effet, Peter Shor a clairement déclaré que c'est l'algorithme de Simon qui a inspiré son désormais
célèbre algorithme quantique
pour la factorisation des entiers, qu'on verra dans quelques leçons.
Et c'est la fin de la Leçon 5.
Dans cette leçon, on a examiné le
modèle à requêtes, et on a vu une progression d'exemples
d'algorithmes quantiques
qui présentent des avantages sur les algorithmes classiques
dans ce modèle.
Il y a en fait beaucoup plus
de connaissances sur le modèle à requêtes et les algorithmes quantiques pour d'autres problèmes que
je n'ai pas abordés.
Donc si tu trouves ce
modèle intéressant, il y a encore beaucoup
à apprendre à son sujet.
Notre prochaine étape sera de s'éloigner
du modèle à requêtes et de se diriger vers un modèle de calcul
plus représentatif
des types de problèmes qu'on pourrait espérer résoudre en pratique.
J'espère que tu me rejoindras pour la Leçon 6, où on se concentrera principalement sur
la mise en place d'une base pour l'étude des algorithmes quantiques.
Et de là, on passera à des
algorithmes quantiques spécifiques, dont l'algorithme de Shor
pour la factorisation des entiers
dans les leçons suivantes. Au revoir jusqu'alors !